[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin guten abend ihnen allen
katja sie dabei mir mit jeder menge
fußball gezeigt und einigen sehenswerten
toren schirm gut nahm im bundestag da
ging es heute hoch her und damit beginnt
unser themen überblick
aus für die impfpflicht nach hitziger
debatte stimmte der bundestag gegen den
antrag für den die bundesregierung
geworben hatte
warnung vor großoffensive die
ukrainische regierung befürchtet
verstärkte angriffe auf den osten des
landes und ruft die menschen zur flucht
auf
streit um kosten und verteilung beim
bund länder gipfel fordern die
ministerpräsidenten mehr unterstützung
um geflüchtete zu versorgen
[Musik]
im bundestag wurde heute gegen eine
impfpflicht gestimmt aber auch gegen
keine impfpflicht alleine dieser satz
verdeutlicht wie bemerkenswert und
turbulentes zuging auch eine niederlage
für kanzler scholz der die einführung
einer impfpflicht versprochen hatte
monatelange komplexe diskussionen gingen
den verschiedenen vorschlägen voraus
vier modelle standen zur wahl aus reihen
der ampel eine impfpflicht für über 60
jährige das wurde abgelehnt genauso wie
der antrag der union er ist ein im
register einzuführen und später über
eine impfpflicht dann zu entscheiden der
vorschlag von fdp vize kubicki der eine
impfpflicht ablehnt fiel genauso durch
wie der von der afd auch die impfpflicht
im gesundheitswesen wieder abzuschaffen
also viermal nein und jetzt andreas
huppert fasst es zusammen mit ja haben
gestimmt
296 die schadenfreude bei der afg
riesengroß die enttäuschung bei denen
die die impfpflicht ab 60 wollte neben
der bundestag sagt nein zu einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht eine klatsche
auch für den bundeskanzler und seinem
gesundheitsminister hatten doch beide im
zuge der korona bekämpfung darauf
gesetzt
schuldzuweisungen sind fehl am platz wir
müssen hier zusammenrücken
gespräche müssen geführt werden ohne
vorbehalte wir müssen versuchen jetzt in
den nächsten wochen doch noch ein
neuanfang für die allgemeine impfpflicht
zu schaffen niederlage auch für viele
grüne sie schieben das scheitern der
union in die schuhe cdu csu würden
parteipolitik über den schutz der
bevölkerung stellen
[Musik]
von wegen schimpft die union anstatt
ihren antrag eine impfpflicht nur bei
besonders schwere epidemie lage
einzuführen abzulehnen hätte die ampel
zustimmen müssen wenn man für den
eigenen vorschlag keine mehrheit findet
aber ein anderer vorschlag auf dem tisch
liegt der dem offensichtlich doch
ziemlich nahe zu kommen scheint dann
muss man dem zustimmen das hat die ampel
aus politischen gründen nicht gemacht
überhaupt ist es heute nicht der tag für
anträge auch der von wolfgang kubicki
und anderen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
grundsätzlich abzulehnen fällt durch
aller appelle zum trotz es ist nämlich
nicht die aufgabe des staates
erwachsenen menschen gegen ihren willen
zum selbstschutz zu finden und die afd
sie scheitert mit dem versuch die
bereits geltende impfpflicht in der
pflege und in krankenhäusern wieder zu
kippen und sieht gar die verfassungen
gefahr
[Applaus]
nur radikale
verfassungsfeindlich
sie ist eine totalitäre anmaßung eine
entwürdigung des individuums vier
anträge alle gescheitert in sachen
allgemeine impfpflicht steht alles
wieder bei null
da war was los im bundestag gunther love
energy in berlin alles in allem eine
denkwürdige abstimmung welches signal
geht von diesem ergebnis aus also für
die wichtigsten beteiligten auf jeden
fall kein schmeichelhaftes der sowohl
union als auch ampel die ampel parteien
haben im eigenen interesse taktisch
agiert die ampel wusste von vornherein
dass sie für eine impfpflicht keine
eigene mehrheit hat und wollte das mit
einem parteiübergreifenden verfahren
gerne verdecken die union hat das nicht
mitgemacht hat die gelegenheit genutzt
an dieser stelle und gerade heute
vorzuführen das ist diese eigene ampel
mehrheit nicht gab und ein möglicher
kompromiss bis dabei unter die räder
gekommen die frage ist wie kann es jetzt
weitergehen es gab ja schon ein angebot
erneut zu verhandeln von der union und
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gesagt man muss auf einen neustart zu
steuern das ist allerdings nach diesem
tag schwer vorstellbar und das was vor
allem hängen bleibt ist dass beide
seiten die impfpflicht offenbar momentan
nicht als so wichtig ansehen dass sie
die parteipolitik hinten anstellen das
geht jetzt mit beiden parteien mit
beiden platten nach hause danke für die
einschätzung suck unterlag nach berlin
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
da spricht der kreml am abend von
bedeutenden verlusten für russland sei
das eine gewaltige tragödie auf der
anderen seite warnt der ukrainische
aussenminister vor massiven angriffen
der russischen armee im osten und süden
des landes zu zehntausenden verlassen
die menschen die region in stark
umkämpften städten wie der hafenstadt
mariupol gibt es aber auch welche die
bleiben nina kurschilgen und alexandra
vacano berichten hast du angst mein
kätzchen hab keine angst sagt die
achtjährige valeria leise seit mehreren
wochen lebt sie mit ihrer schwester
mascha ihrer mutter und den großeltern
unter der erde von mario pohl ihre oma
starb hier neben den enkeln in einem
herzinfarkt nur selten geht die familie
raus die bombenangriffe sind einfach
allgegenwärtig
erst hatte ich vor dem leisesten
geräusch angst aber nach und nach
gewöhnt man sich daran
einmal haben sie es versucht zu fliehen
doch nach wenigen metern kam sie in
einen kugelhagel und drehten wieder um
heute sollte es erneut flucht korridore
geben aus zehn verschiedenen städten hin
nach back mut oder sakko richie auch aus
mario pohl sie haben es dorthin
geschafft julia und ihre kinder lebten
wochen lang in einem keller es gab nur
dreckiges wasser aus einem brunnen und
rationiert es essen
wir hatten schon nervenzusammenbrüche
eine frau hat sich erhängt
präsident vilimsky appelliert ein
weiteres mal an den westen wenn es kein
wirtschaftlich schmerzhafte
sanktionspaket gegen russland gibt und
auch keine lieferung von waffen die wir
wirklich brauchen wird dies von russland
als erlaubnis zum vormarsch zum angriff
angesehen erlaubnis eine neue blutige
welle im donbass zu starten
die donbass region hier kämpfen seit
jahren pro-russische separatisten für
eine unabhängigkeit der region
einige teile haben sie schon unter der
kontrolle jetzt wird hier die nächste
große russische offensive erwartet
die regierung in kiew hat die menschen
dringend aufgerufen zu fliehen so lange
noch zeit ist die folge mehr als 80
kilometer lange staus viele orte gleich
in einer geisterstadt nur wenige sind
geblieben trotz der bomben sie bereiten
sich auf den großen angriff russlands
vor ukrainische soldaten seit jahren
schon kämpfen sie gegen die separatisten
jetzt aber sagen sie müssen sie so
kämpfen wie niemals zuvor
wir gehen zur katrin eigendorf nach kiew
kathrin erwartung russische angriffe
ruft die ukrainische regierung die
bevölkerung im osten und süden zur
flucht auf wie ist das einzuschätzen was
könnte moskau bezwecken
ja dieser grausame krieg der so viele
opfer für die ukraine fordert ist ja für
russland ein misserfolg also was wir
hier erleben in den belagerungsring den
russland hier um kiew über wochen
versucht hat zu schließen der vollkommen
misslungen ist zeigt hier ist putin mit
seiner militärischen strategie
gescheitert die verluste auch auf
russischer seite die massiven soldaten
verluste die die die die armee hat
lassen sich im land natürlich auch nicht
mehr langfristig verbergen putin hat ja
selber angekündigt dass er aus kiew
abziehen wird und den krieg in den osten
der ukraine jetzt verlegen wird ich
denke das tut ja einmal weil er seine
kräfte konzentrieren muss aber auch
glaube ich in hinblick auf den neunten
mai das ist nämlich in russland der tag
des sieges über nazi-deutschland den
putin zu einem feiertag des
nationalismus
dass der armee gemacht hat und da
braucht er im prinzip jetzt im moment
große erfolge also er muss ein sieg hier
vorweisen können und das glaube ich
verspricht er sich von der strategie
jetzt im donbass den krieg dorthin zu
verlagern danke nach kiew katrin
eigendorf die brutalen kriegsbilder von
butscher die haben offenbar auch die
nato zum umdenken bewegt man will der
ukraine noch stärker helfen sich zu
verteidigen offenbar jetzt auch mit
offensivwaffen wie panzern darin sind
sich zumindest die meisten außenminister
einig es bleibt allerdings die frage wie
schnell das dann geht vom nato treffen
berichtet florian neuhann der krieg in
seiner heimat dauert nun schon 42 tage
die begrüßungen bei der nato werden so
herzlich wie selten der ukrainische
außenminister aber ist nicht für ein
paar umarmungen nach brüssel gereist
meine tagesordnung ist ganz einfach da
stehen drei dinge drauf waffen waffen
und warfen wassers bisher hatten
einzelne nato staaten der ukraine vor
allem waffen zur verteidigung geliefert
wie solche dinge abwehrraketen aus
deutschland noch auf dem nato gipfel vor
zwei wochen die absprache keine
kampfpanzer zu schicken um nicht in den
krieg hineingezogen zu werden
doch die bilder der kriegsverbrechen
sorgen dafür dass auch dieses tabu nun
fällt
die klare botschaft des heutigen
treffens ist das alliierte mehr tun
sollen und dass sie mehr tun um die
ukraine auszustatten wir haben die
dringlichkeit erkannt
tschechien etwa hat bereits kampf und
schützenpanzer geliefert und die ukraine
drängt das andere nachziehen wie
deutschland doch die ausgemusterten
kampfpanzer der bundeswehr müssten erst
generalüberholt werden die
aussenministerin ausweichend wir stehen
solidarisch an der seite der ukraine
sind deswegen schauen wir uns auch
gemeinsam all das an was es zu einer
besseren verteidigung in zukunft der
ukraine brauchen könnte die metropole
aber zeigt sich nach dem treffen zwar
vorsichtig optimistisch aber klagt das
würde alles zu lange dauern annalena
baerbock ist da längst weg schon am
vormittag reiste sie auf wunsch des
bundeskanzlers nach berlin um dort für
die impfpflicht zustimmen
dem bundesnachrichtendienst liegen
abgefangene funksprüche vor die die
gräueltaten nördlich von kiew belegen
sollen demnach sollen russische
militärangehörige für die gezielte
ermordung von zivilisten verantwortlich
seien was der creme bislang mit
nachdruck bestreitet und eben wegen der
gräueltaten in der ukraine ziehen auch
die vereinten nationen konsequenzen sie
schließen russland aus dem
un-menschenrechtsrat aus eine
entsprechende resolution auf antrag der
g7-staaten wurde von der mehrheit der
vollversammlung unterstützt 28 länder
darunter china stimmten dagegen etwa ein
drittel der staaten enthielt sich
auch sechs wochen nach kriegsbeginn gibt
es weiterhin massive flucht bewegungen
zehntausende versuchen sich in
sicherheit zu bringen allein in
deutschland sind seit dem 24 februar ca
320.000 menschen aus der ukraine
angekommen bund und länder beraten zur
stunde über die folgen der krise
strittig ist vor allem eine gerechte
verteilung der kosten zur versorgung der
geflüchteten christiane hübscher und
romanesco war
frühstück bei der berliner stadtmission
hier wohnen geflüchtete ukraine schon
seit mehreren wochen die hauptstadt
gefällt ihnen weiterziehen in andere
bundesländer ist für viele keine option
ich habe zwei kinder die hier schon zur
schule gehen allein wegen ihnen ist es
wohl besser hier zu bleiben
ich komme aus kiew einer großen stadt
deshalb finde ich auch berlin sehr schön
hier ist die infrastruktur sehr gut
wer aber übernimmt die kosten für die
hunderttausenden die kommen und
zumindest vorerst auch bleiben die
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidentin
der länder hier bei ihrem
vorbereitungstreffen am mittag fordern
finanzielle unterstützung vom bund all
das man muss es so sagen es klingt banal
aber es ist so kostet eben auch viel
geld gerade bei den kommunen und da muss
jetzt der bund mit in die verantwortung
aus berlin heißt es man gehe derzeit mit
einem dreistelligen millionenbetrag in
vorleistung dass nun der bund will dass
die länder für die ersten drei monate
allein zahlen passt der berliner
bürgermeisterin gar nicht jetzt kann man
sich nicht einfach bequem zurücklehnen
und sagen dann haben die städte halt
pech so kiefer so kann das nicht laufen
wie können die geflüchteten schnell und
unkompliziert registriert werden wie
können sie besser aufs ganze land
verteilt werden und wie integriert man
sie am besten in jobs und schulen um all
das geht es zur stunde im kanzleramt
vieles ist strittig es könnte spät
werden heute
also wieder ein langer abend im
kanzleramt und vor allem mit theo koll
geht es dann wohl ums geld werden den
ministerpräsidenten gerade gehört ja
absolut das ist ja auch durchaus
vertraut wenn bund länder streitigkeiten
besonders lange dauern dann geht es
meist um viel geld in diesem fall wer
zahlt für die unterbringung und für die
versorgung der vielen flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine es gab vor dem heutigen
abend schon fünf verhandlungsrunden
ohne einigung und auch heute höre ich
von beiden seiten also von bund und
ländern dass die positionen noch weit
auseinanderliegen im kern geht es darum
ob die kosten für die geflüchteten im
rahmen des
sozialgesetzbuchs also über
arbeitslosengeld 2 getragen werden und
damit vom bund bezahlt werden oder ob
das asylbewerberleistungsgesetz greift
das klingt nach juristerei aber für
beide seiten geht es dabei ja um viele
hundert millionen bei angespannter
haushaltslage bisher sind die länder in
vorleistung gegangen und wollen jetzt
nicht nur dass der bund ihnen für die
zurückliegenden monate eine pauschale
bezahlt sondern sich auch deutlich an
den künftigen kosten beteiligt im moment
bietet der bund offensichtlich weniger
als beispielsweise bei der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 also alle seiten
stellen sich auf einen längeren abend
ein und fiel danach hätten darüber
berichten bergischen theo koll
bundespräsident steinmeier hat heute
sinti und roma in deutschland um
vergebung gebeten für das was ihnen in
der nachkriegszeit angetan wurde die
menschen hätten in der jungen
bundesrepublik ausgrenzung und
herabwürdigung erlebt von behörden
polizei und justiz seien sie
diskriminiert und kriminalisiert worden
steinmeier äußerte sich anlässlich eines
jubiläums vor 40 jahren wurde der
zentralrat deutscher sinti und roma
gegründet
im zusammenhang mit der flutkatastrophe
im vergangenen sommer in nordrhein
westfalen waren immer mehr vorwürfe
gegen umweltministerin rosa heinen esser
von der cdu erhoben worden jetzt zieht
die konsequenzen und tritt zurück heinen
esser musste zugeben nur tage nach den
überschwemmungen nach mallorca geflogen
zu sein und dort mit mehreren
mitgliedern der landesregierung den
geburtstag ihres mannes gefeiert zu
haben bei der katastrophe im vergangenen
juli starben allein in
nordrhein-westfalen
49 menschen
wir sind jetzt beim sport angekommen und
bei katja und bei ganz viel fußball und
mit enttäuschten münchnern denn ziemlich
verdient hat der fc bayern gestern abend
die erste saison niederlage in der
champions league einstecken müssen viel
zu ideen und kraftlos die bayern beim 0
1 in spanien gegen den fc villarreal
bayern coach nagelsmann fairplay sein
gegenüber emery ausgelassen emotionale
gegensätze schon nach acht minuten da
fehlt die zuordnung in der bayern-abwehr
villarreal mit direktem spiel zum 1 0
durch dann zuma der tabellensiebte der
spanischen liga hellwach
ein sehr schlechtes spiel gemacht
nicht wirklich aggressiv verteidigt die
deutlichste einladung zu einem weiteren
gegentreffer manuel neuers kapitaler
fehlpass corino vermag nicht sie
anzunehmen die niederlage hätte höher
ausfallen können denn bayern chancen
sind selten und kaum zwingend kommen am
nächsten dienstag im rückspiel müssen
die menschen da fürs weiterkommen ein
anderes gesicht zeigen
ziemlich sauer war thomas tuchel trainer
des fc chelsea
sein team kassierte im zweiten spiel des
abends einer 1 3 niederlage gegen real
madrid ausschließlich seinetwegen karim
benzema traf gegen der 21 minute
in der 24
und ziemlich souverän dann auch in der
46 minute
und heute abend empfängt eintracht
frankfurt im viertelfinale der europa
league keinen geringeren als dem fc
barcelona stadion ausverkauft vor freude
grenzenlos
für die fans der eintracht ist es das
spiel der spiele für die fans und wohl
auch für die mannschaft erst abends euro
liegt mit eintracht marie damit voll mit
vollem stadion und von daher jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder ein geiler abend
seit wochen schon präsentiert sich der
fc barcelona in bestechender form vorne
mit den beiden extra und dembélé und
oberwang und vor allem mit dem jüngster
petri ist das team nur ganz schwer
auszurechnen wir suchen immer die
möglichkeiten die chancen für uns auch
herauszufinden
hier habe ich einfach viel mehr spaß
macht frankfurt im fußballrausch denn
der club hätte nach eigenen angaben auch
300.000 tickets verkaufen können
das wird ein fußballfest hat mit 21 ein
werk das glaube ich auch um das wetter
ist total egal jetzt ist glaube ich
jedenfalls nass stürmisch und ziemlich
ungemütlich so zeigte sich heute das
sturmtief nasen in krefeld richteten
umgestürzte bäume schäden an auch in
stuttgart wütete der sturm und deckte
dächer teilweise ab an der nordsee
nahmen einige das wetter dann doch eher
sportlich und freuten sich über viel
wind und ordentliche wählen und es
bleibt leider ungemütlich mehr gleich
mit oesterling unsere empfehlung für 21
uhr 45 lautet heute journal mit
christian sievers dann danke fürs
zuschauen entspannten abend für sie
morgen an dieser stelle wieder barbara
hahlweg machen sie es gut
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die kaltfront die uns heute
überquert hat mit schauern gewittern und
sturm schmiegt sich allmählich an die
alpen und das -tief dazu das zieht nach
osten hin ab das nächste tief nähert
sich von der biscaya bringt viel wind
regen und schnee mit wir schauen auf die
bühne im norden wird es morgen will ich
sein um 80 kilometer pro stunde in der
mitte wird es allmählich weniger noch um
65 kilometer pro stunde und im süden
gibt es bühnen um 100 km/h und in der
nacht da wird es im süden regnen hier
ist die kaltfront noch ansonsten gibt es
nach norden regen in den mittelgebirgen
auch schnee bei tiefsten temperaturen
von zwei grad im hessischen bergland und
9 grad im südwesten
morgen kommt das tief von westen her
erwischt hauptsächlich den süden und
dann gibt es kräftigen regen teils mit
gewittern und auch viel winds nach
norden hin ist es etwas aufgelockert mit
sonnenschein bei höchsten temperaturen
von fünf grad richtung eifel und 14 grad
im südwesten deutschlands am samstag ist
es noch sehr durchwachsen mit schauern
und gewittern dazu viel wind bei vier
bis elf grad spätestens montag wird's
ruhiger und wärmer ein schöner abend